so she mentioned that there's a spot
for people who somehow are not familiar
uh so it's a yellow robotic dog
and
um has been featured in many Dance
videos uh it also has gained an arm
so what can you say about the arm that
spot has about the challenges of this
design
and the manufacture of it we think the
future of mobile robots is mobile
manipulation that's where
you know in the past 10 years
it was getting Mobility to work getting
the legged look emotional work if you
ask what's the hard problem in the next
10 years
it's getting a mobile robot to do useful
manipulation for you
and so we wanted spot to have an arm to
experiment with those problems
and the arm is
um
almost as complex as the robot itself
you know and it's a it's an attachable
payload
um it has you know several Motors and
actuators and sensors it has a camera in
the end of its hand so you know you can
sort of see something
the and the robot will control the
motion of its hand to go pick it up
autonomously so in the same way the
robot walks and balances managing its
own foot placement to stay balanced we
want manipulation to be mostly
autonomous where the robot you indicate
okay go grab that bottle and then the
robot will just go do it using the
camera in its hand and then sort of
closing in on that um the grasp
but it's it's a whole nother complex
robot on top of a complex legged robot
and so and of course we made it the hand
look a little like a head you know
because again we want it to be sort of
identifiable in the last year a lot of
our sales have been people who already
have a robot now buying an arm to add to
that robot oh interesting and so the the
armrest for sale oh yeah oh yeah it's an
option what's the what's the interface
like to work with the arm like is it
pretty so are they designed primarily I
guess just ask that question in general
about robots from Boston Dynamics is it
designed to be
easily and efficiently operated remotely
by a human being or is there also the
capability to push towards autonomy
we want both
in the next version of the software that
we release which will be version 3.3
we're going to offer the ability of if
you have a autonomous mission for the
robot we're going to include the option
that it can go through a door which
means it's going to have to have an arm
and it's going to have to use that arm
to open the door
and so that'll be an autonomous
manipulation task that just you can
program easily with the robot strictly
through you know we have a tablet
interface
and so on the tablet you know you sort
of see the The View that spot sees you
say there's the door handle you know the
hinges are on the left and it opens in
the rest is up to you take care so it
just takes care of everything yeah so we
we want in for a task like opening doors
you can automate most of that and we've
automated a few other tasks we had a
customer
who had a a high-powered breaker switch
essentially it's an electric utility
Ontario power generation
and they have to when they're going to
disconnect you know their power supply
right that could be a gas generator
could be a nuclear power plant you know
from the grid you have to disconnect
this breaker switch as you can imagine
there's you know hundreds or thousands
of amps and volts involved in this
breaker switch
and it's a dangerous event because
occasionally you'll get what's called an
arc flash as you just do this disconnect
the power the Sparks jump across and
people die doing this
and so uh Ontario power generation used
our spot in in the arm through the
interface to to operate this this
disconnect
um that's right in an interactive way
and they showed it to us
and we were so excited about it and said
you know I bet we can automate that task
and so we we got some examples of that
breaker switch and I believe in the next
generation of software now we're going
to deliver back to Ontario power
generation they're going to be able to
just point the robot
at that breaker they'll indicate that's
the switch there's sort of two actions
you have to do you have to flip up this
little cover press a button then get a
ratchet stick it in to a socket and
literally unscrew this giant breaker
switch so there's a bunch of different
tasks and we basically automated them so
that the human says okay there's the
switch go do that part
that right there is the socket where
you're going to put your tool and you're
going to open it up and so you can
remotely sort of indicate this on the a
tablet and then the robot just does
everything in between and it does
everything all the coordinated movement
of all the different actuators that
includes the body and it maintains its
balance it it walks itself you know into
position so it's within reach and the
arm is in a position where it can do the
whole task so it manages uh the whole
body so how does one become a big enough
customer to request features because I
personally want a robot that gets me
beer
I mean that has to be like one of the
most requests I suppose in the
industrial setting that's uh a
non-alcoholic beverage
um of picking up objects and bringing
the objects to you we love working with
customers who have challenging problems
like this and and this one in particular
because we felt like
what they were doing a it was a safety
feature B we saw that the robot could do
it because they they tele operated it
the first time probably took him an hour
to do it the first time right but the
robot was clearly capable and we thought
oh this is a great problem for us to
work on to figure out how to automate a
manipulation task and so we took it on
not not because we were going to make a
bunch of money from it and selling the
robot back to them but because it
motivated us to go solve what we saw as
the next logical step but many of our
customers in fact uh we we try to our
bigger customers who typically ones who
are going to run a utility or a factory
or something like that we take that kind
of direction from them and if they're
especially if they're going to buy 10 or
20 or 30 robots and they say I really
needed to do this well that's exactly
the right kind of problem that we want
to be working on and and so note to self
buy 10 spots
and aggressively push for beer
manipulation
I think it's